Dave Rubin he's hosted the Rubin report
it's a pleasure to have you on the show
and have you in studio in particular you
know Andy no I do know him personally
and I don't know if you've talked to him
but I did see Sam Harris tweeted this
that making light of the attack of Andy
no that basically people that do that
have no idea what this level of
incivility and intolerance can cost us
in the long run yeah so I've texted with
Andy a couple times from the hospital he
is out now and he's doing okay but
obviously there'll be some follow-ups
medically look there are fascists
running around the streets of Portland
but it's not Andy no and it's not the
people trying to report on these people
it's the people that are known as the
anti fascist it's anti vibe these people
that put on masks and attack people and
silence people using violence these are
the fascists and Ted wheeler I mean this
guy I truly can't even imagine being
more of an embarrassment as a public
elected official I mean he's the head of
the police why are those people not all
arrested we've got plenty of video on
this I also think it's sort of
interesting that even in the in the
framing of this that Andy's being
portrayed as a conservative I someone on
the right as if that somehow slightly
excuses it he must kind of be a bad guy
because he's conservative or on the
right I know him well I don't even know
him to be on the right what he isn't
though he's not just a woke progressive
so he's not just a far left in in the
strange political times that we live in
now that automatically makes you a
conservative or someone on the right or
anything like that also of course you
know this happened to happen during Gay
Pride Month
Andy happens to be gay he's also Asian
those are two minority points that he's
supposed to get according to the left
but because those points real quick so I
mean really if you think about it when
the when the Jesse Smollett thing
happened you know AOC and Schumer and
Pelosi and Booker and the rest of the
cab the entire cast of Empire coming to
his defense yeah think about that was I
think about the Democratic politicians
though that did that said this is an
example of what a racist homophobic
country America is some of them still
have their their tweets up Kristen
Gillibrand her tweets about it are still
up yet Andy who's a double minority if
that's the game that you want to be
played yeah he gets attacked and
yeah absolutely not a game I want to
play but it's a game so I listen to you
on podcast 1.5 speed as I walk with and
walk a little bit faster
pretty good absolutely I can do Ben
Shapiro at 1.5 small like yeah I get
yours a little bit easier time but I one
of the things that you come back to over
and over again and I'm curious about
this is the big tech yeah and the
connection between you and others that
are lean right and end up finding
yourselves frustrated about being either
targeted or demonetised
on platforms on which you've built
businesses yeah so there's been a whole
bunch of talk about this last week
project Veritas did a bunch of expose
days with some behind the scenes videos
of leakers and whistleblowers talking
about the way that they're suppressing
video I had an hour-and-a-half
off-the-record conversation with Susan
Susan Wojcicki who's the the YouTube CEO
you know I've got a million subscribers
on there I give them a show that's I'd
like to think as nicely produced as this
one and you know we took a lot of
content it took me about five years to
get email addresses do you think it took
them that long because I did to do
crisis communications for a living yeah
why would it take them five years to get
to you is it that they didn't think it
was a problem
you know I it's interesting because I
really try not to impugn people's
motives however as time goes by if you
keep seeing people that leave it's not
just conservatives I mean that's what I
think your audience really is understand
it's anyone that takes any slightly
right position it's the most marginal
libertarian position yes peace that
connected you with yeah where we are
they're connecting us to the far right
which is hilarious because if you read
the piece which was the front page of
the sunday New York Times and the
premise of the piece is that a bunch of
youtubers are leading people to the far
right but that the guy that they use as
the example of this becomes a lefty at
the end so you know the New York Times
has sort of failed on this CNN has
failed on this they've at least gotten
back to me and we'll see what happens
from there well it's a if you don't
already follow Dave Rubin I'm sure most
of you do but if you don't certainly do
that check it out it's very
thought-provoking and it's good to walk
to as well at 1.5 speak
I walk a little fast alright thank you
for being here thanks Dana